Spider-Man across the spider-verse has
cameos of just about every spider person
you can imagine but if Toby Maguire had
been cast in a major role it would have
had a major impact on the entire MCU
widely regarded as one of the greatest
superhero movies ever made the 2018
animated comic book film Spider-Man into
the spider-verse introduces fans to a
wide variety of spider people from
across the Multiverse all of whom find
their way into Miles Morales Universe
these include Peter Porker Spider-Man
Noir and Peter B Parker the letter of
whom becomes a mentor to Miles despite
being disillusioned with the superhero
lifestyle despite this Multiverse
Centric premise the movie doesn't
feature any cameos from the main
live-action iterations of Spider-Man
those being Tobey Maguire Andrew
Garfield and Tom Holland Peter
as that happens the film's directors Bob
persicetti Peter Ramsey and Rodney
Rothman did consider bringing back
Maguire in particular to play the older
Peter B Parker though these plans fell
through due to concerns about confusing
the audience during an interview with
screen Crush in 2018 Rothman said there
were many thoughts about where we could
put Toby Maguire and others I think
after this film those thoughts might
have a little more traction but before
this movie and introducing the idea of
the spider-verse to the audience I think
everybody was afraid that it would just
really confuse people while the team
behind into the spider-verse backed out
of casting Toby Maguire as Peter B
Parker he would go on to play a similar
version of the character in The 2021
Blockbuster Spider-Man no way home in
that film Maguire reprises his role as
Peter Parker from The Sam Raimi
Spider-Man trilogy acting as a mentor to
a younger alternate version of himself
unlike Peter B Parker this version of
Spider-Man is still optimistic about his
crime fighting career and is more than
happy to impart some life lessons to the
Marvel Cinematic universe is Spider-Man
Maguire's reappearance in Spider-Man no
way home serves as a solid epilogue for
his version of the character but it
doesn't seem like the actor is ready to
fully retire the role following the
release of the 2021 flick Maguire
indicated in an interview with Marvel
that he's very open to reprising the
part again down the line the actor said
I love these films and I love all of the
different series if these guys called me
and said would you show up tonight to
hang out and goof around or would you
show up to do this movie or read a scene
or do a Spider-Man thing it would be a
yes because why wouldn't I want to do
that whether or not McGuire plays
Spider-Man for a future project his
appearance in Spider-Man no way home
technically a
Reverse movies thanks to Spider-Man
across the spider-verse connecting to
the MCU even if Toby Maguire didn't end
up the Elder Spider-Man Mentor for Miles
Morales and Spider-Man into the
spider-verse Jake Johnson's character of
Peter B Parker still borrows a lot of
traits from his Sam Raimi counterpart
apart from the broad beats of their
origin story being the same the
spider-verse version slots in a couple
of Sly references to McGuire's iteration
including his notorious Street dance
from Spider-Man 3 and his iconic upside
down kiss with Mary Jane Watson in the
first Spider-Man beyond that the movie
even mentions Peter once breaking his
back a subtle reference to when Maguire
sustained a major back injury while
filming Spider-Man 2.
my back
oh my back outside of references the two
undergo a pretty similar character Arc
both Johnson's Peter B Parker and
Maguire's Peter are generally down on
their luck characters who end up
gradually getting Jaded by their
superhero career then later becoming
inspired once again both of them face
relationship troubles with their
respective versions of Mary Jane Watson
though they're ultimately able to work
it out most importantly though both end
up being Spider-Man deep into adulthood
based on these elements it's clear that
Maguire's Spider-Man definitely had an
influence on the development of Peter B
Parker even if the actor didn't make it
into the original film his take on the
character is still felt in the DNA of
Spider-Man into the spider-verse
foreign